just tell us what stage is the Imperial
vaccine at so we're at the stage where
we're testing it in our first volunteers
we are doing that very cautiously
because safety is of paramount
importance
so we vaccinated 15 15 volunteers so far
I'm going very slowly and in the coming
weeks we'll be ramping up to include
another two to three hundred
participants and what chance would she
give the vaccine of success I know it's
difficult to put a fig on it but you
think it's greater than 50% I think it's
very difficult to predict one of the
things that we don't understand right
now is what level of immunity you need
to prevent infection if you only need a
very small amount of immunity I suspect
most of the vaccines that are being
developed will actually work but if you
need a very strong immune response or a
particular quality of immune response
we'll see that actually will be a
shaking out of some of these candidates
we hope will be the candidate one of the
candidates and successful but there's no
certainty with any individual approach
it's interesting to hear you say that
there's so much we're still learning
about the immunity that we are given
from the virus and that means that we
need is there a chance that
evacs they might not work at all now I
think that's a very low low risk I think
because there are now so many different
candidates being developed we will see a
number of these coming through and of
course having a lot of different
candidates being developed spreads that
risk of failure I think we're very lucky
in the UK that we have two very strong
candidates the one from Imperial the one
from the Oxford and so with pretty well
placed but it is still not a certainty
that either those two will work and of
course if the Imperial vaccine does work
when is the earliest that people could
get their hands on it so we anticipate
if everything goes really well that
we'll get an answer as to whether it
works by early next year and we have put
in place the infrastructure to make
enough vaccine for the whole of the UK
so assuming that the funding is there to
purchase that vaccine we could have that
vaccine rolled out across the UK in the
first half next year and
with the UK take priority in that's not
really what they would but only because
the UK has funded us up to this stage so
the UK are looking at doing an advanced
purchase of the vaccine so that it's
ready to go that doesn't mean that it's
going to be excluded from being provided
to other parts of the world it's just
that we're living in that space where we
don't know if this vaccine will work as
soon as we know it works
everybody will be queuing up and wanting
to get hold of the vaccine and there's
likely to be a big gap between success
in the clinic and actually being able to
make it available for multiple
populations around the world yeah she
say the kind of rollout feels really key
it's interesting to hear you talking
about early next year because I remember
the time when you know government
ministers were talking about possibly
having a vaccine by September I mean
that feels quite optimistic now doesn't
it I think that feels very optimistic
but you you know that there's again this
all bets are off it's still a
possibility but I think it's a really
really low possibility partly because
the number of infections in the UK have
fallen so much which is a great thing
for the UK but it means making testing a
vaccine and seeing if it works so much
harder so in some ways the better we are
at preventing or reducing transmission
the harder it is to demonstrate whether
vaccine works and that's why we're
looking to do trials in other parts of
the world where the transmission is much
higher what kind of places you looking
to trial it well we're having
conversations with colleagues in in
South America in Africa we don't yet
have the funding to put those trials in
place so we're looking to design the
studies and try and get the funding to
Musa as fast as possible and you're
talking there about some of the
challenges to rolling out a vaccine
partly being a low infection rate are
you also worried that you know people
may not actually accept taking it and
what are the other challenges that you
could see happening well I mean I think
one of the challenges is not not we're
not so worried that people weren't
necessarily accepted there will always
be some people that have hesitancy
around vaccines I think that the wider
pressure is actually that there's such a
push to develop a
maxime that normally we would study a
vaccine for maybe two years before we
made it widely available to the general
public and of course we won't have two
years of safety but this vaccine or any
of the vaccines that are being developed
and so they will still need to be
introduced very cautiously with long
term long term follow-up as that
pressure to get a vaccine in and to get
economies up and running is is really
very strong and the need for a vaccine
it kind of changes the way we think
about the approach and changes the
pressures that would normally be there
do you think there is a bit of a risk as
well as people as you say is so keen to
get this vaccine that you know criminals
could see an opportunity to try and
profit from selling fake vaccines online
for example that's definitely going to
be something that the world is going to
have to look out for we're pretty
certain that as soon as any of these
vaccines are shown to work everybody's
going to want them and there's going to
be a big gap between getting them to
work and getting them available across
the world and so there will always be
fraudsters who may want to you know fill
the space by saying oh I've got this
special deal where I've got a vaccine
and it's not actually the real thing so
that's something that needs to be
watched very carefully you mentioned
there their demand for a vaccine when
one does become available who do you
think should be prioritized in the key
well I think we really need to be
looking at this from a global level and
there are structures that are being put
in place at an organization called
Kovacs which is linking garvey that
makes most of the vaccines for lower
middle income countries available and
sepi and the w-h-o there needs to be a
massive piece of work and I think people
probably underestimate what a huge
effort it will be to go from discovery
to making billions of doses ultimately
that probably needs a number of vaccine
candidates to fill that gap
rather than imagining we'll have one
vaccine that's universally available
across the globe now I'm talking about
the you know need to work
internationally we're not taking part in
that you use vaccine program is that a
mistake or does it not really matter I
don't think it matters at this stage
because everybody
just working so fast trying to move
things so quickly that you know success
will come from many different avenues so
in some ways we haven't even got the
luxury of time to look back and say
should we be involved in other schemes
we just need to keep our you know feet
to the grindstone and just go as fast as
we can
yeah and certainly it's an expose as if
the team at Imperial is doing exactly
that now while we've got you I know that
you've been extremely focused of course
there on the vaccine and but I just
wanted to get your opinion on lock down
being eased you comfortable with the
speed that lockdown is being used in the
UK I think that's always good you know
it's always a delicate balance between
trying to keep the number of infections
the transmission rate they are value low
as possible but also making sure that
the economy doesn't stall and everything
come to a you know a complete gratin you
just stop operating and what I suspect
we'll see is that there will be you know
several rather than waves you know
cycles of bars coming back in different
parts of the UK and an events like we've
seen in Leicester where we have to have
regional lock downs and I think we're
going to be living with the kind of
opening up closing down scenario
probably until a vaccine is available so
quite a long while then I guess before
those real normal comes back again and
do you think it would help to make face
coverings compulsory in shops and so on
so I'm not a global health a public
health expert so I'm not the right
person to answer that but this clearly
we know that that face masks do have
some effect in reducing transmission
rates so I think where people can't
socially distance it will make sense now
when you start to get down to which
precise scenarios you should or
shouldn't be wearing a mask it becomes
more complex